今天我們來聊一個很有趣的案例，Penelope Health 這家公司，他們做的事情其實還蠻顛覆傳統認知的。
怎麼說？是做什麼的？醫療這塊通常都很難有大改變吧，特別是支付和保險。
他們拿到了一筆 8700 萬歐元的資金，目標是把醫療保險的理賠、政策審核這些超級冗長又複雜的流程，變成像電商一樣即時。聽起來有點不可思議對不對？
嗯，有點。醫療保險是高度監管的產業，政策複雜、變動又多，還有各種法規限制。要做到即時，這難度不小，一般公司可能連想都不敢想。
對，這就是讓我詫異的地方。一般人會覺得這是不可能的任務，因為光是整合各家保險公司和醫療院所的系統，就是個天大的工程。
而且成本肯定不低。他們具體怎麼做到「即時」的？聽起來有點像科幻片。
他們的 CEO Dr. Sohum Patel 說，醫療保險的規則很混亂、碎片化，又一直變。Penelope 就是要把這些複雜性，轉化成可靠、即時的參考資料。
所以他們是做一個平台，把所有保險公司的政策規則都拉進來，然後統一標準化嗎？這聽起來很耗費人力，而且政策一改，他們平台也要跟著改。這模式撐得久嗎？
撐得久。原文提到，Penelope Health 的平台目前已經涵蓋了超過 2 億美國病患的保單，橫跨 15,000 種以上的程序和藥物代碼。他們是用科技去解決問題，不是靠人力。
2 億病患？這數字有點大。所以他們是把這些複雜的數據變成一個單一的基礎設施層？
對，就是這個「單一基礎設施層」是關鍵。醫療公司可以用這個平台即時查詢保險覆蓋要求，比較不同支付方的政策，還能簡化他們內部流程。
這樣一來，原本醫療院所要自己去一家家保險公司查詢政策，或是透過很多客製化的連結來處理，現在只要連接這個平台就好。這確實效率提升很多。
我覺得最厲害的是他們覆蓋了這麼廣的範圍，而且還得到了像 Thoreau 這樣的 HealthTech 基礎設施平台的合作和投資。這證明了他們的模式是被認可的。
那如果我是個創業者或企業主管，我能從這裡學到什麼？感覺這種規模的投資和技術，離一般中小企業有點遠。
我覺得最值得學習的，是他們看到了一個「慢動作」的痛點，而且不只看見，還敢於用「即時化」去顛覆。即使在一個看似難以改變的產業，他們也找到方法。
也就是說，任何一個產業，只要有行政效率低落、流程複雜的地方，都可以思考看看有沒有辦法用科技來「即時化」？
沒錯。像我們一般上班族，雖然不能直接去開發一個這麼大的平台，但這個概念可以帶到工作或生活裡。
怎麼帶？
比如說，你手邊有沒有什麼工作流程，是每次都要花很多時間去查資料、比對規則的？如果能把它整理成一個共享的、即時更新的資料庫，是不是就能提高效率？
聽起來像是把我們常問、常查的 FAQ 或是 SOP，變成一個會自己動、會自己更新的系統。
對，或者像我們去銀行辦業務，或是處理一些申請，如果每次都能像在電商購物一樣，即時看到進度、即時知道結果，體驗會好很多。
這個概念其實很有意思，就是在你認為已經是極致複雜、不可能提速的地方，去找到那個「即時化」的突破口。
好像也提醒了我們，很多時候我們習慣了慢，就以為那就是極限。